i think it's fun making passwords i mean
i don't like to do it from
9am to 10 o'clock at night but that's
what comes with having a business you
need to do the orders you don't just get
money for doing nothing
welcome to
keeping up with the moon slash england
my name is mira modi and i love passport
making as you know
one big happy family
i make passwords that are very
secure and i have a website where i sell
them for two dollars each and i send
them by postal mail
i roll dice to make strings of numbers
use the string of numbers to
get corresponding words in the dashboard
dictionary
i roll dice five times for each word but
you do that six times for one password
so i realized 30 times
and it
produces random words that
have a lot of entropy which means it's
not easy for the computer to hack
it kind of like turned into a thing i
would do like if my mom's friends are
like come over and like hey can you make
me a couple passwords and i'd do it then
i was like oh let's make it into a
website and
here i am and the website
is
kicking off and i'm really excited about
that some people like say being popular
in school is like the best thing ever i
think like this is so much better people
actually like learn from this and
that's good